I'd say so okay um but let's talk about
I mean what was it like having an entire
night of Dancing With the Stars
dedicated to you
know I think people that know me realize
that my ego didn't need that but I mean
are you kidding me my whole country
tonight I hope was watching on Disney
plan I hope I made you proud I was
pooping my pants I was so excited about
it all and um it just was so cool I've
like I've always been a huge part of the
dance Community you know for 20 years
I've written and arranged and produced
music that I I'd always thought about
trying to make it in a cinematic way
where whether you were in a dance
student you were a four-year-old kid or
you're 94 that you could move to it and
have something to inspire you and I
called Derek about eight months ago and
I was like Derek those people are my
people like but we're so disconnected I
feel like we're not and he's and we said
like well what if we do this and that
was kind of our this was our idea so the
fact that this happened tonight you
couldn't see it but a million times off
camera Derek and I turned to each other
and went
oh he did it we did like this is amazing
it was so much fun for me and
judging people because I'm a judgy kind
of person
do you know what I mean I'm even judging
you right now and I'm going to tell you
something 12 out of eight oh my God shut
up stuff I'm not kidding even in your
mask I don't know what's underneath
there but I know it's got to be good
stop anyway
you also gave out quite a few tens even
when other judges I gave away two
I think
three maybe three
I would have given away more if I'm
really good there was people that blew
me too there were people that just
listen
they're so brave and Valiant especially
when they don't have a background and
dance then there were people that
surprised me like demilio Charlie and
her mom I didn't I had no idea that they
they had that and Wayne Brady is a just
a bad bad human being who does
everything so
um there were just some really beautiful
poignant moments and it meant so much to
me genuinely that I got to be part of it
and they used my music and I was there
were points where I was emotional but I
didn't want to be too cringy because
um you know I want to look sexy but it
was really emotional for me it was a
really beautiful night this was I'm not
going to sleep I have to go now I told
my wife to go buy lemons and um so I'm
gonna go and suck on them so that I stop
smiling and uh that's it
um you know and you and Derek obviously
like you have you guys have a bit of a
bromance
um what was it like getting to work on I
mean that number was utterly incredible
I mean what was it like getting to work
on that with him and what do you like
most about working with Derek I think
after the the years that we worked
together now I trust him implicitly and
I know that for him good is the enemy of
great and I know that when we do
something that dude has my back it's
funny the first thing I did last night
was call my manager and said Bruce we
are in good hands this guy is I think
he's the greatest in the world at what
he does and I I'll say before I've said
it again
he is
going to be one of the the greatest that
comes out of our generation he's not a
dancer Derek's not a dancer Derek is a
director Derek is a Visionary Derek is
is so much more than just any one thing
and I I just want him to put me in his
first feature film because I think he's
like got some baz luhrmann that he can
do like I know he does I know he's what
type of role would you play in the film
anything he wants I'll be an extra if he
wants uh I just know the movie will be
has anyone ever won Academy Award for
extra work
because I feel like they would create a
category just let's just see how I do go
ahead and call it
action background
it's so hard not to look into the camera
that's why they won't let me do the
extra work it'd be hard yes
um
lastly
um you know any of
the UPS wedding
whenever you go I'm gonna be I'm not
it's not really to sing it's more to
drink and have free hot dogs but can I
just say something before I go
absolutely I just did a tour of my
country
and my people were the greatest in the
world and if they keep this in Canada
you kill me I love you so much and you
made me so proud and you filled me up
and I hope I go out there and I kick
some butt for you you you're my people
and I love you to death